sí
tras esta corta conversación se
determina si es necesario hacer una
prueba pcr este es el trabajo de una
brigada de kobe en quito en la lucha de
los pobres uno de los barrios más pobres
de la capital ecuatoriana un equipo
médico presta atención médica gratuita a
los que creen que pueden ser portadores
del virus
eso está bueno porque ahorita que
estamos en crisis en mayoría que estamos
en trabajo no tenemos plata para salir a
hacer tu prueba en particular pagados no
tenemos lo tengo como nosotros somos
entera
si tenemos miedo porque mucha gente en
este barrio mismo mucha gente muchos
vecinos han fallecido
las pruebas se etiquetan y se envían al
laboratorio los pacientes recibirán los
resultados en un plazo de 72 horas desde
agosto estas brigadas médicas se
recorren toda la ciudad una iniciativa
del ministerio de salud para realizar
pruebas en masa especialmente en los
barrios más pobres
es una población que está llena de
personas que trato sobre el bajo que
viven con menos de dos dólares al día
entonces ellos generalmente son
recicladores de basura gente que vive
del comercio gente que no puede esperar
a irse a atender porque tienen un montón
de tanto niños que son entre por
promedio de familia entre tres o cuatro
hijos que tienen que alimentar y hay una
persona que suele moverse de la casa
entonces esa persona no puede dejar de
trabajar un día
tras meses de lucha contra el virus los
médicos se muestran más optimistas pero
siguen siendo prudentes
es un poco panorama un poco más
optimista un poco mejor al principio
aquí todo era un caos total la tasa de
complicados ha disminuido bastante la
tasa de contagios esa es la que si se
sigue manteniendo pero el virus ha
pasado de ser un virus tal vez un poco
mortal un poco más complicado o tal vez
un poco más atenuado
gracias a este contexto sanitario
favorable el 12 de septiembre se puso
fin al estado de emergencia sanitaria
quito está tratando de volver a la
normalidad pero la capital de 2 millones
de habitantes se esfuerza por recuperar
su cara habitual las calles de los
barrios más frecuentados están ahora
casi desiertas como aquí en el mariscal
el barrio de la fiesta la periodista
susana morán no reconoce su ciudad natal
yo solía venir acá frecuentemente como
igual para un viernes de distracción
finalmente veo que ya eso no existe en
este lugar es un lugar muy triste como
decía y bueno ahora vi muy poca gente en
los locales consumiendo o bebiendo cosas
[Música]
en toda esta ciudad fantasma muchos
negocios tuvieron que cerrar a los bares
y restaurantes que han resistido la
crisis económica les cuesta ver la luz
al final del túnel
terrible simplemente perdida todos los
meses
en lo que uno ha perdido
en 300.000 en el caso de casa mucha
gente quizás más
y eso no se va a recuperar
simplemente uno tiene que asumir esa
pérdida y ver su espacio para
recuperarse pero no en un plazo largo
porque un plazo corto simplemente es
imposible en un plazo inmediato tampoco
esta recuperación va a tardar años un
contexto económico lento que está
llevando a un aumento de la inseguridad
ha aumentado el número de robos por
ejemplo en las calles el número de robos
a celulares a personas a casas también
algo que era un fenómeno que ya era
controlado antes de la pandemia no era
tan extendido
vemos nuevos brotes de delincuencia que
están provocando este tipo de estragos
también a la ciudadanía y yo creo que es
una consecuencia directa también de la
falta de empleo
los ecuatorianos quieren volver a la
vida normal pero siguen teniendo mucho
miedo las autoridades sanitarias se
esfuerzan por evitar una segunda ola que
parece inevitable y esperan que la
estatua de la virgen de kito vele por
sus habitantes